[Music]
[Applause]
this guy knows all about campus all
about partying pat 40 sports illustrated
senior writer where did you go to
college pat
university of missouri an above average
partying school i would say i don't know
i don't know how high we will rank on
this list
did you have a famous classmate at
missouri
well there was this guy he was in
journalism school he dropped out three
hours short of graduation i'm not sure
what became of him but his name was brad
pitt
he was he was in journalism yeah he was
in advertising at missouri
did you have classes with brad pitt
if i did i didn't know it
you know i might have i i tried to stay
away from the ad
classes but you know we might have had
some of those you know history and
principles of journalism class uh what
did you make of uh week zero for college
football why did we have to have week
zero
so that uh nebraska fans could
absolutely lose their minds that's why
we had to have weeks
i mean that was really the only major
takeaway from it is oh my gosh what a
disastrous start for nebraska and i gave
the big ten credit they have given us
stuff to watch early with that game and
then with a bunch of good games this
weekend so we're not sitting around
watching you know big ten schools
against directional you uh but that was
whoa that was a bad start for nebraska
is the the heisman spencer rattlers to
lose
uh i think that might be a little too
simple but you know what you plug him in
at the way he ended last year if that
carries over and he has that second year
bump up like baker mayfield did his
numbers should be spectacular and if
they win their games then he would be a
logical favorite but i think you look at
sam howell at uh at north carolina and
there's going to be you know somebody's
going to put up a bunch of stats for
ohio state somebody's going to put up a
bunch of stats for alabama maybe do dj
or younger lay at clemson so there's
some some other alternatives for now
ohio state kicks off its season against
minnesota
what other the uh other intriguing games
do you uh have this weekend
that one's super intriguing uh you know
thursday night we've got some stuff but
uh friday we have north carolina
virginia tech and then saturday so much
i mean lsu at ucla and lsu was displaced
by hurricane ida you know how prepared
are they to go into the rose bowl to
play chip kelly's best team
uh miami brings a lot of confidence and
experience in against an inexperienced
alabama offense uh we'll see if they can
keep it close and then i'm going to uh
georgia clemson which is a big time
heavyweight game but both sides could
have coveted issues there we'll see if
there are players missing on on both
sides if i said that you could have ohio
state clemson alabama or everybody else
in america for the national title
would you take
those three or an outlier i would
probably take those three since my
top two going into the season or alabama
ohio state uh that said i don't i don't
think they're
way above
georgia and oklahoma uh but i still you
know past history and recruiting uh i
would put those three certainly if
you're gonna give me those three i'd
take them who is the most intriguing
player
slash person in college football this
year i'm going to say bryce young the
quarterback at alabama he has not played
a meaningful snap yet and he's
gotten six seven figures in endorsements
uh he steps into a position that as we
have seen has produced three straight
nfl starters uh first round guys that
are you know going on to do well and and
he's got a new offensive coordinator
bill o'brien coming from the nfl you
know does it work the way it has the
last
several years at alabama he's a super
talent but again haven't seen him do it
at the college level yet the most
intriguing coach this season in college
football is
steve sarkesian texas uh you know
stepping in they they spent a lot of
money to get rid of tom herman they just
made one of the most audacious moves in
the history of college athletics to jump
to the sec and while they're not in
there yet that's still that's the
context for this season
and sark
he's coming from the you know the the
alabama
uh uh rehab mode there you know where
they do they they recycle coaches and
give them a second chance and we'll see
is he a better coach than he was at usc
at washington because he was okay there
but he wasn't great uh can he get texas
up to a level where they can go into the
sec and compete eye-to-eye with people
you have the big ten acc and pac-12 this
is sort of they're in the on-deck circle
just like texas and oklahoma and the sec
but
it feels like there are so many
questions and not any answers with this
alliance here that they just want to be
able to say hey we got veto power with
these three conferences against the uh
sec
i don't know i'm trying to figure this
out of
is there another shoe to drop with this
or is it just sort of going to move
along in a snail's pace
i i think that there were some you know
obviously some huge action and
significant reaction but mostly i think
this was
them saying hey we we all need to do
something here we're not sure exactly
what we're doing yeah but we got to do
something and so this alliance yeah what
it does
it gives a proactive win to three
relatively new commissioners who need
something to show their constituency
like hey we're on top of this
secondly
i think the biggest thing it does
is try to slow down
an espn sec power play and say we're not
voting for your expanded playoff if it's
all going to be an espn property because
two of our conferences the big ten and
the pac-12 are closely in line with fox
and we don't want to give everything to
the to you have everything continue to
be with espn especially now that you
have even made it very clear that sec
gets most favored nation status with
that network so i think this is as much
a way to stop
an espn sec
move to just have even more influence
over the way college football uh is run
i'm surprised that the sec
didn't reach out to
oregon usc uh and unless we didn't hear
about it but i i would have i would have
truly had a sec east and an sec west and
you could have put texas and oklahoma in
with usc and oregon and washington and
arizona state
do you think that greg sankey reached
out to those schools
i i i wouldn't be shocked if he did uh
you know as you said i mean if you're if
you're going to go big why not go
humongous okay i mean you've gone to 16
what's to stop you now from continuing
to go further and just try to do
everything you can to put even your one
competitor really which is the big ten
in terms of revenue and and fan bases
and all that stuff even further behind
uh the one thing though
i mean the pac-12 is different we know
that and usc as much as they like
football to want to be
back to being prominent in football it's
also a pretty serious academic
institution as is most of the states
that all the pac-12 schools in this in
the state of california and i'm not sure
they're ready to just say okay let's
make this incredibly
different move just for football reasons
well that's what i wondered about the
big ten
that does the big ten pick off a couple
of schools i mean it didn't go well with
with rutgers and nebraska and maryland
but do you you know do you
i wouldn't be sitting back waiting
but i don't know if this is the right
move for the big ten to be in bed with
the ac sort of be in bed with the acc
and the pac-12
well i mean i think the one thing you
look at is why are they doing it because
they don't necessarily need the other
two whereas the other two need the big
ten more but i think your point of veto
power of three versus one uh is
significant there
uh the other thing again again i just
think
most of these schools look at this more
as an academic alignment at the
presidential level
you know who are we aligned with
academically and now that's where you
could see the big ten saying yeah we'd
like to align with those california
schools uh and sure give us virginia and
north carolina and hey notre dame maybe
you know uh i just i that wouldn't shock
me if it ends up going that way i do
think
we seem
headed towards an era of
the power schools in each conference
exerting themselves a little bit more
ohio state michigan penn state saying
you know what
we should be getting more money than
illinois and purdue and iowa and usc and
and oregon those saying maybe the same
thing out there i just think that we're
going to see
schools trying to at least flex their
muscles for either a better arrangement
within their conference or to get out of
their conference and go join other
powerhouse schools i know you were at
the olympics you were working but your
daughter was swimming for the united
states
what was it like to
go to what were you covering your
daughter
in her event when she was swimming
fortunately no we had somebody else
there from sports illustrated to to
handle coverage that night and so i got
to just watch as a
as a
bite your lip fan in the middle of the
media seating because that's there was
no fans to go sit with anything like
that so i mean i'm just i am there in
the in the i was cheering in the press
box i was violating that rule let's
let's be clear about that but uh what's
that feeling like though
your daughter is swimming in the
olympics
yeah and you see
you see her dive in yeah it's
unbelievable i mean you can't i i failed
to find the right words for it but just
to see her come out on the pool deck
with her relay teammates wearing the
stars of stripes cap and it says 40 on
the side it's like that is my kid that
i've watched swim since she was five
years old in the little neighborhood
meets you know and through elementary
school high school college and now the
pinnacle uh it was overwhelming it was
extremely emotional
uh and then as soon as she was done i
ran down to the mix zone where you can
actually interact with your athletes now
we were separated by barriers because
coveted restrictions but
just to be there with her right after
that moment that's that's a lifetime
highlight for sure did you cry oh yeah
absolutely i i didn't write there with
her but as soon as she left the room
yeah then the water works started and i
cried like eight times when she made the
team at olympic trials
you're a
softy
i admit it uh hey great to talk to you
as always we'll check in with you during
the season thanks again for uh joining
us
my pleasure dan thank you pat 40.
sports illustrated